[Music]
they used to say it's as american
as mom and apple pie can't say that
anymore both are banned
we first noticed this a few weeks ago
when maybe the single dumbest member of
congress
member from st louis called cory bush
use the term
birthing people rather than mothers that
sound like something out of a dystopian
science fiction novel
but now in just a few weeks it's gone
mainstream now the term birthing people
has the endorsement of the white house
at a hearing yesterday the deputy
director of joe biden's budget office
explained
you really have to be a bigot to use the
term woman
the budget requests 26 million dollars
to reduce
maternal mortality and eliminate
race-based disparities
and outcomes among quote birthing people
i've never heard the term before can you
explain what it means
uh absolutely uh there there are certain
uh people who do not uh have uh
gender identities that apply to female
or male
and so we think our language needs to be
more inclusive in how we deal with
complex issues
this is maybe the least complex issue
ever addressed
mothers give birth fathers don't
children are the product of a mother any
father that's not politics it's biology
and if you're forcing the rest of us to
deny it then you are a
totalitarian who seeks to control
reality itself
which is beyond your purview by
definition it's not just the budget
office that's doing this
this show has obtained a document from
the federal reserve the internal website
at the fed that
its employees read it's a memo on
bias-free
language but of course it's very biased
it instructs staffers not to use
words and phrases that may be considered
offensive what's offensive
founding fathers man-made
and singular pronouns like he or her
now the fed is controlling monetary
policy it's also totally destroying the
economy in case you haven't noticed but
right or wrong it's supposed to be a
political why are they trying to control
our language because they want to
control our minds
but the fed victor davis hanson one of
the few people we know smart enough to
see what this really means he's a senior
fellow at the hoover institution and
we're honored to have him
tonight professor thanks so much for
coming on what should we take from this
thank you you know i think it's
characteristic of all bureaucracies that
when they can't solve
an existential problem they always go to
the triviality as if they've
done something right because look at the
federal reserve you know
we may have six to seven percent
inflation right now per annum and one of
when we have 2.8 mortgage rates that's a
gap
and what are they doing they're looking
at the pronouns and the same thing is
true with the omb
we have a 30 trillion dollar deficit of
debt and a
trillion dollar annual deficit they
don't have a clue how to handle that but
they do want to focus on these
trivia and you know it's also
characteristic i think tucker of the
left
they always want to be a cultural
revolutionary
so they want to go back in the past and
cancel people out
and rename streets and buildings and
universities and topple statues
and change the language that's what the
soviet union did and then they think in
the present they
starting in year zero and then here we
go in the future that according to our
plan so the biden administration
believes that
after a thousand years of usage in the
english language they and their
infinite genius have invented new words
that nobody ever thought of and
therefore
this is the beginning of a new i don't
know paradise or utopia
it's also i think tucker it's sort of
giving an answer for a question that
doesn't exist or a solution
for a problem that doesn't exist it's
kind of like the juicy smolits
syndrome there is no victimization
rampant so they have to come up with
these psychodramas
so they can feel that wow we're a
polarized society and we're not
we don't have equity or fairness but
these words were here for
a reason they're specific i think it's
very important that people realize that
while the founding fathers their
achievement was not because they were
male but they transcended their sex
they weren't just chauvinist or racist
they created ideas out of the
enlightenment
that meant that you would have the
woman's suffrage or you would have civil
rights
because that was the logic of all men or
created equal they didn't have to do
that
there's nothing in the constitution that
mentions race or gender
and so that they were male is you know
incidental but it's important to see how
they did i think it's important for us
to
not say that queen victoria or queen
elizabeth or madame curie or helen
keller
was a woman and that's who she was but i
also think that
it it enriches history to know that they
were women women
and they transcended their situation so
i don't want to go
and recreate language uh and then in an
orwellian fashion and make us all just
sort of
nothing collective blah and that's what
they're trying to do and
is there really a problem do we have a
lot of transgender people
you know pouring into hospitals that are
pregnant and saying you know what i'm
going to have a
medical crisis if you get the wrong
pronoun pronouns are helpful
they enrich the language they
distinguish reality that's what language
is for
it's quickly do you find it interesting
that they are
so offended by fertility and nature
and the idea that people reproduce and
that's okay
you know that we men and women come
together
and create new life like the whole thing
is repulsive to them why is that
well i think it's because it started
with the feminist movement that they
felt that that impaired a woman's
future but i think it also reflects
reality tucker that
the age when people are getting married
having children buying a home
buying a house has gone from mid 20s to
mid 30s
and our crisis right now is that we're
not reproducing ourselves we're about
1.8
rather than 2.1 or 2. and and we're
suffering from what prolonged
adolescence these
these children or they have adult bodies
but they have the minds of children they
don't want to grow up
aoc is a good example of a person who's
suffering from prolonged adolescence and
she said she doesn't want to have
children because
of climate change so it's a it's a
phenomenon i don't know if it's because
of 1.7 trillion dollars in student debt
or the economy but they just don't want
to
take off their training wheels and go
out and experience life and it's
it's adventures and dangers yeah it's
sad even sad for
sandy cortez you know kind of missing
the best part the fun part
i think it is victor james hanson
appreciate you coming on tonight thank
you
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else